this is why we learn openings just to  get a position you understand well put  your piece on good squares  middle games we come up with plans here  magnus came up with this attacking plan  and then uh yeah just a bit of  calculation and that will finish it off  anisha's not even looking at his screen  right now he's ready to resign  he knows this last game has been  a bit brutal yeah  going to be interesting too here from  magnus carlsen so in the first major the  oslo esports cup magnus was struggling a  lot with being sick he was a sick guy  the first five days or something of that  tournament and he didn't win it he was  struggling with his form we know he is  out to win this tournament and what a  start to the day it's over winning also  game four magnus carlsen takes all three  points in this big battle against aneesh  geary but it start for minus cross and  he's walking out of the miami arena  towards sweden i'm excited now to see  what kind of